we asked the BuzzFeed community to send
us their secret menu items and we're
gonna eat them yeah hopefully they're
good I'm from New York so I've only had
it a couple times probably three times a
month I'd go probably once a month and I
go protein style and I go horn never
tried the secret menu before also it's a
secret so like whew I'm holding it oh
that good there's nothing to hate about
those this is like a grilled cheese
sandwich but with me somebody brought me
this and I had to pay for it I'd be
freaking irate right now it needs some
sauce or it needs something and or
lettuce tomatoes and a bun this is like
the inside of your mouth after you when
you're eating in and out this is the
inside your stomach my stomach just
growled in like happy things good my
stoner walked up to the cashier edit out
and was like I want I want a patty on my
fries and the guy was like don't you
just want a burger and fries is like no
no no no on it
this is just a combative ultimate
in-and-out hack right here it's good it
adds a little bit of flavor
asko salty yeah she might as well grab
like the Pacific Ocean went through it
onto this plate
she makes me really sad for America oh
my god guys holy [ __ ]
oh my god this is incredible I'm gonna
have to have jaw surgery after taking
one bite I have a mouth it's kind of
daunting hey you ready I have to
practice on I think that's just too much
I know if I eat this in the morning I
wouldn't have to eat until the next day
this restores my faith in America this
is the next president of our country
mm-hmm
delicious this is the best one so far oh
my I love it
yeah ton of flavor it's like but moist I
know a lot believe that word but I like
that word that kinda looks healthy I
would almost go vegetarian for this you
gotta try it and I'm sorry about my bad
manners mom that's fantastic he's gonna
do the whole thing huh okay
she doesn't know what she's talking
about amazing I'm also done but amazing
Wow the ice creams a little melted oh
it's perfect
no any more today I found $100 and I got
a river flow yeah he's on $100 yeah